[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 1er février au mali
la situation ne peut pas rester en
l'état déclarations du porte parole du
gouvernement français gabriel attal ce
matin au lendemain du renvoi de
l'ambassadeur de france par le
gouvernement de transition pour voir une
expulsion jugé injustifié selon berlin
jean henri iv dernière estime lui que
les autorités maliennes ont pour seul
partenaire les mercenaires de wagner la
version malienne et russe est tout autre
nous verrons nouvelle escalade de
tensions entre bamako et paris qui pose
cette dernière à s'interroger sur son
avenir dans le pays
les émirs goutines dit espérer que
l'occident et la russie trouve une
solution à leur crise tout en accusant
washington d'utiliser l'ukraine comme un
instrument pour entraîner moscou je cite
dans un conflit armé le président ne
s'était pas exprimé depuis plusieurs
semaines sur cette crise ils jugent
clair que les états unis et l'otan ont
choisi d'ignorer les préoccupations de
moscou pour sa sécurité boris johnson
juge ce soir que la russie reculer
soulagé sur l'exhortent de choisir la
voie de la diplomatie aujourd'hui
anthony blinken et sergueï lavrov sont
reparler moscou demande toujours des
garanties pour sa sécurité
en france les ehpad et orpea dans la
tourmente les résume les résidents
subirait des conditions d'accueil
dégradantes un scandale dont se saisit
l'exécutif jean castex promet d'agir et
de ne pas rester inactif face à ces
accusations présumés deux enquêtes
administratives sont ouvertes le pdg
d'orpea sera lui auditionné demain par
les députés alors la france traite telle
manne les personnes âgées on ouvre le
débat dès 21h et on attend vos réactions
sur le télégramme verte et france
[Musique]
au mali gabriela talent juge donc que la
situation ne peut pas rester en l'état
la présence militaire française doit
évoluer une réaction au lendemain de
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur français à
bamako un renvoi injustifié pour berlin
est une nouvelle étape franchie dans un
contexte de fortes tensions entre paris
et bamako hélène masquelier
une expulsion qui ne passe pas suite à
l'annoncé de bamako paris décide de
rappeler son ambassadeur avant qu'ils ne
soient sommés de quitter le territoire
au lendemain de la nouvelle le quai
d'orsay ne mâche pas ses mots
ce n'est pas un événement du à
l'irresponsabilité je réitère mes mots
du ahly légitimité d'un gouvernement de
coup d'état qui va nous faire enrayer
notre lutte contre le terrorisme
l'expulsion signe une étape de plus dans
l'escaladé des tensions entre les deux
pays une décision en réponse à de
récentes déclarations de hauts
responsables français remettant en cause
la légitimité des autorités de
transition au pouvoir au mali
cette mesure fait suite aux propos
hostiles et outragé à du ministre
français de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères tenue récemment à la
concurrence à la récurrence de tels
propos par les autorités françaises à
l'égard des autorités maliennes un dépit
des protestations au même poids élevé on
reproche au gouvernement de transition
de repousser la tenue des prochaines
élections mais dans le pays selon un
récent sondage plus de 90% des maliens
se disent en faveur du report du scrutin
néanmoins en ce qui concerne l'expulsion
de l'ambassadeur français l'opinion est
divisée
si c'était moi on allait
[Musique]
en demandant aux autres de nous
respecter nous en
france
illégitime
entre les amener
une passe d'armes dans un contexte de
fortes tensions avec le pays sahélien la
france militairement engagés dans la
région depuis 2013 envisageait de
réduire ses effectifs d'ici 2023 un
désengagement qui pourraient survenir
plus tôt que prévu
alors faut-il repenser l'avenir des
militaires français aux manies et qu'est
ce qui a mené à cette expulsion de
l'ambassadeur français de bamako place
maintenant au décryptage
avec nous pour en parler régis le
sommier grand reporter ert france qui
connaît très bien le malaise de mali
pour y avoir fait plusieurs reportages
bonsoir régis à nos côtés également bam
s'est mouillé 6 et parlementaires
membres du conseil national de
transition bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous également bakary traoré consultant
et spécialiste du sel bonsoir bakary
traoré alors faction au gouvernement de
transition la france et les européens se
trouve un petit peu au pied du mur au
dos au mur je dirais régis c'est l'heure
de vérité
un tournant dans cette opération mais
clairement il ya une forme de 6-2 un
tournant oui on est à huit ans de
l'opération serval puis l'opération
barkan qui a suivi il y à une remise en
cause de la part d'un pays le mali
meilhan sang qui a décidé des
soubresauts burkina faso qui vient de
subir un coup d'état aussi et une remise
en cause en fait globalement de 7,2
cette présence et peut-être aussi de la
pertinence finalement de cette opération
barkan où va-t-elle la france on sait
c'est déjà on replie retirer du nord du
mali elle est concentrée maintenant en
dans une zone qui va de commandes du
gourma au liptako avec en gros la base
de gao donc c'est vraiment le le la zone
des trois frontières
la france a quitté ses bases de kidal de
tessalit tu de tombouctou pour se
replier donc il ya déjà une situation de
retrait la france et puis il y à cette
situation de comment j'irai de guerre
diplomatique
entre le gouvernement de transition et
le gouvernement français qui s'est
exacerbée on sent bien que
d'un côté les maliens on dit avait dit
par la voix de leur premier ministre
qu'ils avaient l'impression d'être
abandonné en plein vol ç'avait été le
table le des termes utilisés comment
marché auquel maïga à l'onu et depuis
cette situation n'a fait qu'empirer avec
un dialogue de sourds et puis au milieu
de tout ça
cette discussion avec donc la smp wagner
qui est venu un petit peut dynamiter les
choses en tout cas les les durcir je
dirais également aussi la mise au mali
du la mise à l'écart du mali de par la
cedeao qui a accès à accélérer les
choses et tout ça aujourd'hui arrive on
arrive à la situation où le mali décide
d'expulser l'ambassadeur de france et là
on est con on a passé quand même un cap
on va évidemment parler à ces
problématiques notamment jean yves le
drian s'est s'exprimé l'assemblée
nationale cet après-midi s'est brouillée
si c'est justement sur l'expulsion de
cet ambassadeur français comment vous
vous vous l'expliquer parce que c'est
assez grave en d'expulsion un
ambassadeur c'est très symbolique
comment justifier comment expliquer en
effet compte tenu des rapports entre
l'art france les rapports historiques
entre la france et le mali je pense que
c'est une première mais aussi je rappel
il n'y a à peu près deux ans la france
avait demandé au mollet de rappeler
l'ambassadeur du mali en france bien
quand même dans
dans le sens inverse c'était du jamais
vu effectivement je dirais quelque part
je suis solidaire de mon gouvernement
pas parce que je suis malien parce que
je suis parlementaire de cette
transition mais à un moment donné il est
temps qu'on respecte ces peuples
africains il est temps qu'on respecte
les maliens les propos du ministre de
monsieur le ministre le drian ou de mal
et moi d'en parler depuis quelques jours
un moment donné il était temps que on
leur montre aussi que nous existons nous
sommes un peuple est souverain même si
nous sommes en difficulté même si nous
avons nous avons fait appel à la france
en janvier 2013 à travers l'opération
serval pour nous aider mais je rappelle
aussi qu'au même s'il suite à
l'engagement de la france contre kadhafi
et par ricochet le mali est tombée
aujourd'hui c'est le burkina le peut le
niger voire même peut-être la mauritanie
demain
bakary traoré s'est
tassée parce que c'est vrai que les
lectures habituelles les voix qu'on
entend en france notamment dans les
médias on parle beaucoup je regardais ce
matin les chaînes d'information la
france humiliée et c'est un point
d'interrogation se poser la question est
aujourd'hui un mail hier sur le plateau
nous dit eh bien nous voilà on s'est
senti humilié et cette décision
d'expulsion c'est aussi le résultat de 2
comment la france a traité le le mali
oui tout à fait je confirme musique et
bien des du le pain et motel 6 et c'est
le sentiment général de haut niveau du
mali ici
ces déclarations de monsieur yves le
drian 23 des autorités de la transition
qualifié d'illégitime d'irresponsables
je pense que tous la calade grippe a au
niveau diplomatique entre bâle et la
france étaient parties de la déclaration
publiée dans macro du 10 juin 2021 pour
ma trombine a lancé bien sûr dédiant la
fin des bars kanata coopération oui son
réaménagement au niveau 2 au niveau des
souris trois frontières et donc
les choses sont laissés à l'écran mais
d'autres julie boulet on constate que la
france n'a pas tenu compte des trophées
majeurs ou dans leur est et du golan n'a
pas tenu compte du fait que c'est bien
le mani densité dans cette situation où
le plan de
retrait du made in n'a pas tenu compte
et à diriger le gouvernement
c'est à dire que le gouvernement
précédent
le bateau est bien qui a négocié des
choses qui à nous des rapports avec la
france et bien ce gouvernement a été
renversé par le
colonel américain et bien ce titre des
sept états du changement de gouvernement
n'a pas tenu
roots pour toi au niveau du plan de
l'été de le débat qu'un deuxième à mon
avis c'est le discours que le pénis le
cheval camargue a étudié à la tribune
des nations unies en septembre dernier
où il a déclaré que le mot ni fait sa
thèse abandonné en plein vol parce que
suite à cette déclaration du maquereau
un des façons reculé de latéral la
france a choisi est bien dorée tirée par
quatre points stratégiques notamment
kidal notamment tessallis notamment et
aux banques tout et projets majeurs
aussi et bien c'est cette
diversification des partenariats de
manière à finalement initiés
diversification des partenariats qui a
abouti à l'arrivée de l'état russe dans
une contre la population ou bien cette
opération apporte et bien tout ce qui
m'attire à l'état malien
l'allemagne elle est juste qu'ils
apprennent à celle des deux années c'est
à dire la cub aérien et les
renseignements et d'ailleurs
cette coordination avec l'armée russe
oddo constate rugby attendait pas porter
des fruits notamment le démantèlement
des différentes bases terroristes à
travers le centre vous ici à travers le
mur de poubelles je pense que cet été
ces trois faits majeurs n'ont pas été
tenus contre le dispositif de retrait
des points stratégiques et si bien qu'il
ya eu des séquences mesure la première
conséquence est bien sûr c'est le fait
que l'état malien a témoigné finalement
une des nuls les accords de défense
j'étais pardonnez-moi la caresse traoré
parce que c'est vrai que comme vous êtes
3par donnant sur le plateau on va
essayer de voir tout ça un parent alors
il ya eu évidemment en france des
réactions a notamment à l'assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui
puisque le possible retrait un militaire
français du mali a été abordé on
rappelle que gabriel à thann a rappelé
aujourd'hui que paris progressivement
réduisez la voilure et qu'on allait
continuer à le faire a rappelé porte
parole du gouvernement plusieurs
réactions des députés aujourd'hui l'élu
communiste par exemple jean paul lecoq
malgré le courage de nos soldats au mât
aile l'armée française a échoué appelant
donc à ce retrait des français régis le
sommier est ce que c'est aussi simple
que ça c'est un échec cuisant et il
faudrait pas retenir aujourd'hui
selon en tout cas ce député la question
est dans l'air la difficulté en fait la
france rencontre au mali
peut-être comparé à mon sens à la
difficulté que les américains ont
rencontré en afghanistan d'un
déploiement qui finalement n'a pas tu es
au départ répond à un impératif de
sécurité et de protection je rappelle
que les colonnes donc djihadistes alliés
comment des miliciens touareg venus de
libye ont déferlé sur le mali et que la
finalité de l'opération serval justement
ça a été d'arrêter de les empêcher
justement d'aller puis vers le sud
7 comme les américains eux étaient
intervenus en afghanistan pour en
chasser al qaïda et les éléments
terroristes qui avaient frappé
l'occident là pour le coup s'il
s'agissait de deux commandes de venir en
aide au mali
dans un premier temps moi je me souviens
à l'époque
le discours de tombouctou de de
commandes de françois hollande l'ovation
le fait que les soldats français canton
patrouiller dans les villes les enfants
venaient à courait vers l'est vers les
véhicules blindés quand je suis passé au
mali dans la zone de ménaka notamment en
avril dernier c'était plus du tout le
cas il y avait plus du tout cet
enthousiasme est plus du tout s'est tu
sais tu comment gérer cette cette
adhésion de la population le sentais
bien alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé la
mission barkan a été je dirai comment
élargi la france et ses alliés la
coalition dû superviser finalement est
un territoire qui partait de la
mauritanie pour arriver au tchad avec
4500 soldats 10000 membres de la minus
ma si on inclut les 1000 tchadien ça
fait très peu pour une zone qui est
immense et le général michon l'a
récemment avoué était interviewé par la
lfp au moment où j'étais au mali en
fin décembre il disait qu' il y avait ce
sentiment d'échec de sécurisation de
pacification du sel il l'admettait parce
que la tâche était considérable le
problème principal me semble-t-il n'est
pas le problème de l'efficacité des
français ou l'efficacité de la coalition
l'a vu récemment au burkina avec le raid
qui s'est opérée qui a détruit environ
60 djihadistes ya on est capable
d'intervenir et on a eu des résultats
mais le problème c'est qu'à présence
française ne s'est pas transformé en
parallèle avec un retour des services
publics dans certaines zones au mali
avec un retour de l'armée malienne dans
certaines je dirais que une partie du
territoire et est tombé d'une certaine
façon en jachère ce qui est terrible
c'est que dans le même temps que la
france était présente et qu'elle
continuait à développer cette action
contre les groupes armés très terroriste
est bien dans le même temps le mal le
mali partait à vau de l'eau je pense
qu'une expliqué une des explications
parce que quand on parle le colonel
putschiste ils sont pas arriver comme ça
je voudrais mon but n'est pas de les
défendre nécessairement mais quand on
voit le pédigré du colonel a thing aux
états c'est pas quelqu'un qui est là
pour s'enrichir c'est pas quelqu'un
c'est quelqu'un qui était chef des
forces spéciales malienne qui a kiss est
confronté justement aux terroristes sur
le terrain et c'est pas quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un de plutôt intègre et
aujourd'hui on les voit comme des
militaires sécessionniste mais il faut
voir aussi que le pouvoir malien qui
leur a pressé qui a précédé étaient
aussi s'est avéré incapable justement de
rétablir 7,7 comment dire cette
administration est en tout cas de
contrôler ce pays qui s'est effritée
dans le même temps la france est en
était là et là et le hélas là comment la
présence française etc c'est comment
dire s'est prolongée peut-être trop
puisque c'est systématique si je prenais
un exemple à des fins des américains en
afghanistan c'est que au final la
population commence à considérer la
france comme une puissance occupante et
non plus comme une puissance qui vient
aider le pays est évidemment le néo
colonialisme et ses pouvoirs que le mali
avec une transition dans les années 60
il a obtenu son indépendance il a été
marxiste léniniste ila été voilà il
s'est opposé et voilà donc il ya quand
même une tradition aussi de saint lô
maligne et le néocolonialisme est apparu
à mon sens aussi à cause beaucoup de
maliens qui recense que vient de nous
décrire régis le sommier bon c'est
rassurant que ça vient à la part d'un
grand reporter français c'est pas un
malien qui le dit il vient de trouver ce
qu'il a vu que lui qui régissent le 6022
dire clairement ce qu'il avait lu sur le
terrain l'évolution de 2013 à 2021 ou
2022 effectivement un moment donné quand
vous êtes sûrs dans un pays étranger et
avec des résultats il ya des réussites
il faut pas tout remettre en cause à
cause de quelques envolées lyriques de
part et d'autre il ya eu et des quelques
réussites est ce que je voudrais qu'on
tire de la suite de régis le sommier ce
que le premier ministre je gagne mes
gars a dit à la tribune des nations
unies moi je le prends comme un cri de
coeur
jamais on n'a jamais demandé le départ
de la france dont les autorités
maliennes si même si si et là quelques
moyens le disent nous on n'a jamais
vraiment l'état malien n'a jamais
demandé le départ de la france c'est la
france qui a décidé vous venez de le
rappeler mais je dirais la talent ce
matin sur france inter le dis très
clairement tu vois il faut ils vont
réduire la voilure mais un pays quand
même ça sous-entend
une anticipation vous voulez partir ou
veut réduire la voilure non on ne peut
pas rester les bras ballants sachant que
comme je le disais tantôt cette guerre
nous est tombé dessus depuis la libye
aujourd'hui on sait ce qui s'est passé
on a un homme d'expérience risque s'il
vient de dire qui est le cas aujourd'hui
qu'on aime qu'on n'aime pas qu'on aime
les militaires ou pas il ya un résultat
probant qui est là depuis six mois il ya
des résultats sur le terrain on récupère
des centaines des villes et de villages
et des dialyses qui sera battu
quotidiennement aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui il ya un résultat qui est là
cette montée populaire autour des cinq
colonels ci n'est pas si ce n'est pas
quelque chose d'anodin habituellement
dans ces zones là on paye les gens pour
voter pour quelqu'un est aujourd'hui pas
plus tard que le 14 janvier il ya une
démonstration de force où le public nous
le peuple malien est sorti dans toutes
les grandes villes on a vu ne serait ce
qu'un bon locaux je pense qu'il y avait
au moins vingt mille personnes n'y a pas
de ceux qui parlent de sentiments
anti-français ya pas de sentiment anti
français pour ceux qui connaissent vos
mac os
le boulevard de l'indépendance la place
de l'indépendance la ville centre
culturel français personne n'a été
touché vous prenez le drapeau français
là bas donc il n'y a pas de sentiment
anti-français fille juste peut-être qu'à
un moment donné les plus hautes
autorités françaises devraient commencer
à respecter ces peuples africains et de
par là moi je vois par exemple je dirais
aujourd'hui juste pour terminer je suis
un peu jaloux de la solidarité
européenne seraient tous les pays
européens soutien de la france et de
l'autre côté vous avez tous les pays
africains qui sanctionne le mali et la
guinée voilà un petit peu vous avez 27
pays européens il n'y a pas de
frontières nous pays pauvre enclavé en
s'auto sanctionne et aujourd'hui on le
voit la côte d'ivoire on voit
apparemment cet après midi et quelques
coups de feu en guinée-bissau il ya une
semaine le coup d'état était consommée
au burkina faso où allons nous il est
temps aujourd'hui d'évaluer barkan de
cerval abarkan est aujourd'hui que nous
a remis aussi sont en train de monter en
puissance et du population le ressentent
ça c'est palpable en tout cas le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères a aujourd'hui jean yves le
drian interpellé par l'opposition
notamment par le député jean lassalle en
qui parlait d'un camoufler historique à
protéger isolement du mali et fustigé
d'ailleurs les seuls partenaires dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure les
mercenaires je suis teint selon lui de
wagner écouter le ministre des affaires
étrangères français le combat contre le
terrorisme
monsieur le député lassalle se
poursuivra et se poursuivra au sahel il
se poursuivra aussi avec l'accord des
autres pays de la région et je vous ira
aussi en soutien des pays du golfe de
guinée qui aujourd'hui voit la porosité
des groupes des frontières permettent
aux groupes terroristes de pénétrer dans
le nord de ce territoire donc notre
volonté est intacte et ce n'est pas un
événement du à l'irresponsabilité je
réitère mes mots du ahly légitimité d'un
gouvernement de coup d'état qui va nous
faire enrayer notre lutte contre le
terrorisme le na li 7 une question
propre au mali et je dirais que l'
isolement du mali est elle aujourd'hui
qu'il n'a que seul partenaire les
mercenaires de wagner c'est tout ce
qu'il trouve le seul partenaire aux jo
de du mali c wagner tous les autres
veulent que le mali retrouve la
démocratie et le combat contre le
terrorisme jean yves le drian cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale et sur la
présence présumée de wagner je vous
propose d'écouter
la version russe tout de même dimitri
bodianski représentant permanent de la
fédération de russie auprès de l'onu
quant à l'implication présumée du groupe
wagner une fois de plus cela n'a rien à
voir avec les responsables russes le
groupe n'est pas soutenu par l'état
s'il est sur le marché alors c'est à
chaque pays de décider s'il va coopérer
avec cette entreprise ou non le mali
n'est pas une exception dans ce cas je
ne vois aucune raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement malien ne peut pas prendre
la décision souveraine de s'engager avec
cette compagnie militaire ou avec une
autre compagnie militaire de ce genre
d'un autre pays je veux dire
il y a aussi une coopération
gouvernementale entre la russie et le
mali mais c'est une autre histoire
voilà pour les deux versions même sens m
envoyer si ces gens voyaient réagir aux
propos de jean yves le drian non à dire
que le mali est isolée par l'ensemble la
communauté internationale ça ce n'est
pas vrai aujourd'hui je le disais on
travaille avec la russie le droid eris
viol de confirmer enfin qu'on nous parle
de wagner ou de aujourd'hui jusqu'à
preuve du contraire moi je suis
parlementaire dans le contrôle de
l'action gouvernementale
on n'a pas de preuves nous qui à wagner
non c'est quand même que l'état russe
car company le mali est d'ailleurs si
ces sont des relations historiques
signés depuis le temps de nos pères de
l'indépendance ce n'est pas forcément
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui oui on se tourne
vers d'autres partenaires la france à
des conventions multilatérales avec deux
pays pas forcément avec les européens et
les américains pourquoi on empêcherait
le mallié d'avoir d'autres partenaires
qui sont autres que la france ou des
européens bakary traoré oui boullier
hager
et oui tout à fait à ce que
ses propos auraient été les de monsieur
les clients encore
sur deux ans près de lille d'irrespect
et des discours et des disques au début
du cobaty
une diplomatie c'est sur les sites c'est
roddick de l'échec d'une diplomatie
les propos discourtois et les invectives
tu penses que ces sons et des six est
symptomatique de l'échec d'une
diplomatie et c'est tout à fait légal
table c'est tout à fait regrettable
d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui
le mali
fait le premier pas la première à
effectuer la coupe de france je pense
que ça pouvait être l'occasion
de voir la condition sa position et de
décéder maquereau et l'équateur ses
complices et y avait dû faire dans cet
apport en défense et qui tienne compte
bien sur la coque de respect de la
constitution du mali sa sobriété
ceux qui aiment autant dé souligner en à
venir dans cette crise diplomatique
entre le mali et la france c'est que ça
fait dix ans que le manier dans ce
bourbier le manière et à elle la france
bouge et malheureusement ce que le
maniement d'un état des nappes et
aériens et des renseignements pour doper
les opérations militaires n'ont pas été
au rendez-vous et si bien mieux
aujourd'hui et bien même si bien la
france sur les tribus mani et celui de
croire dans d'autres parties du sahel je
pense mme est un peu eh bien la france
ne tient pas compte du fait que c est
abordé à des troupes au sol mais ne pas
besoin de tout notre amateur mais on les
aime beaucoup plus
vous réalisez mondialiste et bien si
l'accord n'existe pas d'âge pas te
s'engage pas dans cette voie je pense
que hambach france bancs en bois l'échec
n'est pas l'apport à sa gestion de la
caisse dans les ca n est il ya une autre
point important qu'il faut se fier à mon
avis c'est que ça fait dix ans que le
cri vie cette église pour les jours
presque toutes les semaines s'est
dégourdi le solo ii ne soit amené qui
sont ils sont combien ceux qui sont en
bas souffrent si des lieux aujourd'hui
l'armée a finalement c'est hier soir ça
fait une semaine que l'armée
dans le nord et des sentiments dit avec
la neutralisation des antennes une
trentaine de pirates east et nativité
l'émirat justice tout cela démontre
vraiment des mots qui en disent on se
défend
avec
la russie
n'est pas isolé donc quel droit
effectivement d'avoir les partenaires
qu'ils veulent non alors il ya une wii
et le mali n'est pas forcément isolé
peut-être pas autant que en tout cas c
est clair qu'il ya eu quand même une
dune une fermeture des frontières et
depuis la rupture d'un certain nombre d'
échanges entre le mali et les principaux
pays que limitrophes a en revanche sur
ladite déclaration de commande de jean
yves le drian moi je voudrais revenir
sur le caractère alors effectivement
illégitime illégale parce que le
gouvernement ait putschistes et que le
gouvernement s'appelle le gouvernement
de transition moi je constate que la
qualification de gouvernement de
transition n'est pas propre au mali elle
existe aussi au tchad et qu'on la voit
pas vraiment remise au tchad où comme
par hasard c'est le partenaire le pilier
central de barkan et c'est là qu'ont été
rapatriés nos forces spéciales
d'ailleurs et et une partie de
l'état-major donc on demande pas autant
aux tchadiens de procéder à une
transition démographe démocratique
le gouvernement burkinabè depuis limoux
semaine est aussi un gouvernement de
transition et le gouvernement de guinée
est aussi un gouvernement de transition
donc si vous voulez ce ces putschs sur
cette multiplication des pushs commence
un petit peu à faire gérer boule de
neige en afrique il ya une là il ya
quelque chose sur lequel il faut
s'interroger parce que on peut pas voilà
comment stigmatiser uniquement le mali
en lui disant conduisait des élections
conduisait des élections le problème du
mali c'est une question à mon sens alors
il ya tout un tas de composantes et
d'affaires politiques internes au mali
qui demanderait beaucoup de
développement et que un parlementaire
est plutôt a même plus à même que moi de
d'expliquer en revanche sur la question
sécuritaire moi je voudrais revenir là
dessus il ya un vrai problème pour tenir
des élections au mali aujourd'hui on est
dans une dans une situation il faut
regarder les choses moi les dernières
opérations que j'ai suivi avec mark cane
notamment je parle de la une opération
et une légion étrangère en 2020 toute la
zone en fait entre même ménaka et la
frontière c'est une zone en fait la
plupart d'un peu de des populations ont
disparu il reste incertaine et il ya une
guerre ethnique énorme là c'est le
territoire de l'olivier s comment voulez
vous conduire des élections au milieu du
territoire de logis est ce qu'au milieu
du territoire d'aqmi tant que l'aude les
autorités maliennes n'auront pas repris
contact soit avec des tractations parce
que ces tractations existe avec ces
groupes y compris des groupes qui sont
aujourd'hui des classes déclaré groupe
armé terroriste parce que il faut qu'ils
aient un dialogue il faut que refaire
revenir ccc commencé groupe est en tout
cas tenté d'apporter une solution pour
que le mali reprennent contrôle de son
territoire et pour le moment ce n'est
pas le cas donc qu'est-ce que ça va être
ça va être des élections où ben oui on
va dire voilà encore une fois les votes
sont achetés et beaucoup ya beaucoup de
ressentiment là dessus par rapport aux
précédentes élections déjà donc voilà
les conditions aujourd'hui ne sont pas
réunies et voilà et la junte au pouvoir
en effet n'est pas arrivé au pouvoir par
hasard elle n'est pas arrivé est arrivé
parce que avant globalement le le
comment toute la période ibrahim keita a
quand même été une période de
désagrégation totale du mali avec une
corruption extrême donc voilà il ya
aussi une explication interne au mali et
qui aujourd'hui explique ce qui se passe
merci beaucoup neigé ce sommet bas est
mouillé cissé bakary traoré d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce décryptage
les discussions diplomatiques sur la
crise ukrainienne se poursuit visite
aujourd'hui du premier ministre hongrois
à moscou viktor orban qui s'est
entretenu avec le président russe
vladimir poutine elle ce dernier s'est
exprimé pour la première fois depuis
plusieurs semaines sur les crises
ukrainienne on retrouve notre
correspondante wad claireaux à moscou
bonsoir antoine actualité oblige les
tensions avec l'ukraine ont donc fait
l'objet d'une mise au point en
conférence de presse tout à l'heure
oui stéphanie tout à fait il ça si il
s'agissait à la base d'une réunion
bilatérale classique entre les deux
chefs d'état vladmir poutine et viktor
orban
concernant les problématiques propres
relations entre les deux pays mais vous
l'avez dit l'actualité chaude s'est
invité dans la conférence de presse
entre les deux hommes un journaliste en
effet interrogé vladimir poutine sur les
tensions d'ukraine et la réponse écrite
de washington aux demandes de garanties
de sécurité de moscou le président russe
a alors de nouveau expliqué la logique
la proche de la russie estimé que ces
exigences avaient été ignorées écoutez
malgorn le principal objectif des états
unis et l'endiguement de la russie voilà
en ce sens l'ukraine elle même n'est
qu'un instrument pour atteindre cet
objectif cela peut être fait de
différentes manières l'une d'entre elles
est de nous entraîner dans un conflit
armé nous analysons attentivement les
réponses écrites reçu le 26 janvier des
états unis et de l'otan mais il est déjà
clair et j'en ai informé le premier
ministre or ban que les préoccupations
de principe de la russie ont été ignorés
l'otan et les états unis sont désormais
au courant vladimir poutine estime que
leur réponse n'est pas à la hauteur des
attentes de moscou pour rappel les
autorités russes sont placées au coeur
de leur demande l'arrêt de l'expansion
de l'alliance atlantique vers l'est
particulier en ukraine des garanties de
sécurité qui pourrait bien être de
nouveau abordée à l'occasion d'un
déplacement des manuels macron à moscou
vladimir poutine en a parlé en sa
qualité de président de la france bien
entendu pays signataires des accords de
minsk mais aussi en tant que président
du conseil de l'union européenne
merci antoine gayraud en direct de
moscou et autres entretiens autour de
l'ukraine aujourd'hui celui entre les
chefs de la diplomatie américain et
russe en échange par téléphone entre sa
klm rohff et anthony blinken qui n'a pas
permis de désamorcer cette crise on en
parle avec un autre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet un bon soir
thomas que vous retenir de ce coup de
téléphone aujourd'hui
et bien c'est un entretien téléphonique
entre sergueï lavrov et anthony blinken
qui a duré une trentaine de minutes et
ce qui est intéressant dans ce genre
d'exercice assez de comparer la version
des deux parties prenantes à ces
échanges on commence avec le côté
américain où il ya eu un communiqué du
département d'état qui est finalement
assez similaires à ceux ayant suivi les
précédents entretiens entre les deux
chefs des deux diplômes acier alors tout
en appelant à maintenir le dialogue avec
moscou washington il réitère son
attachement à la souveraineté de
l'ukraine et demande des actes concrets
à la russie écoutait
le secrétaire d'état a exhorté à une
désescalade russe immédiate et au
retrait des troupes et des équipements
de la frontière ukrainienne il a
souligné qu'une invasion de l'ukraine
aurait des conséquences rapides et
sévère et a exhorté la russie à choisir
la voie diplomatique
et puis du côté russe on comprend que le
sujet important c'est la demande de
moscou d'avoir des garanties sur une
expansion de l'otan vers les pays de
l'est et plus particulièrement en
ukraine sujet sur lequel est revenu le
chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov avec une pointe d'optimisme
écoutez le
aujourd'hui j'ai confirmé à anthony
blinken que c'est un sujet que donc je
ne passeront pas sous silence nous
allons insister sur une conversation
franche sur une explication franche nous
voulons comprendre pourquoi les
occidentaux ne veulent pas remplir ses
obligations ou bien pourquoi ils le
veulent uniquement quand cela sert leurs
intérêts anthony blinken est d'accord
sur le fait qu'il ya un sujet à
éclaircir nous verrons où cela va mener
on comprend donc il ya une forme de
statu quo dans les discussions
actuellement entre moscou et washington
à l'instant le porte-parole de la
diplomatie américaine a démarré une
conférence de presse il a dit que les
états unis attendaient toujours la
réponse de moscou aux demandes
américaines formulées à la semaine
dernière il explique qu'une voie
diplomatique est toujours possible mais
à condition d'une désescalade militaire
dans la région merci thomas bonnin en
direct de washington
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
javier moro fondateur de strates paul
bonsoir xavier mot merci d'être avec
nous le chef de la diplomatie donc
exhortant on vient d'entendre ce mardi
son homologue russe à une désescalade
immédiate dans le même temps un
quasiment le premier ministre boris
johnson qui affirme ce soir qu'il existe
un danger clair et imminent
d'intervention militaire russe en
ukraine on a décidément l'impression de
tourner en boucle
oui je pense qu'on a encore au moins
jusqu'à la fin du mois de février où les
occidentaux vont nous jouer ce
psychodrame
cela dit je pense que les choses vont
plutôt dans le bon sens d'une part parce
que si vous lisez la presse ukrainienne
et bien en fait les ukrainiens eux ne
veulent absolument plus du tout de cette
crise plusieurs fois le ministre de la
défense le présent c'est nice qui
lui-même a dit qu' il ne fallait pas
il fallait arrêter de jeter de l'huile
sur le feu donc on est toujours un peu
dans ce paradoxe c'est qu'on a toujours
l'impression entre blinken et lavrov on
avait déjà cette impression quand ils se
sont rencontrés mais on l'appareil après
le coup de téléphone c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont pas négocié la même chose blinken
parle de l'ukraine sa gaine lavrov parle
des garanties de sécurité que la russie
demande à l'otan et parce que pour les
russes la question de l'ukraine et
régler les russes n'ont pas l'intention
d'en mais à l'ukraine ils en ont ils
n'ont absolument aucun intérêt est donc
la seule question qui se pose c'est les
garanties de sécurité et ces garanties
de sécurité pour l'instant washington
n'est pas prête à les donner mais les
deux camps sont partisans de continuer
les discussions ce qui ce qui est une
bonne chose d'ailleurs vladmir poutine a
conclu sa conférence de presse avec
viktor orban là dessus en disant
j'espère que ça va que ça va continuer
et qu'on va arriver à quelque chose
globalement je pense à donner moi mais
bon temps pourri johnson ennuis
persistant il dit ils jugent vital que
moscou reculer choisissent la voie de la
diplomatie avertissements qu'une
intervention militaire donc serait un
désastre pour la russie et le monde on a
le sentiment que c'est voilà qui
pourrait être familier on est deux à
danser
tout seul ben oui si vous avez tout à
fait raison de le dire parce qu'il est
tout seul boris johnson le l'angleterre
de boris johnson n'est pas le seuil du
dix neuvième siècle elle ne domine pas
le monde et c'est très bien qu'il ait
pris l'initiative d'aller à kiev dans le
même moment il ya son ministre de la
défense qui vient d'arriver à moscou
pour rencontrer sergueï choïgou le
ministre de la défense russe donc on va
voir ce que ça va donner mais je pense
surtout que
johnson en fait des tonnes parce que
justement aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
grand chose derrière lui la personne qui
compte aujourd'hui c'est enfin le l'état
qui compte la nation qui compte pour la
russie c'est ce sont les états unis
s'est absolument pas l'angleterre qui
est je dirais un joueur de second ordre
dans cette histoire alors venir poutine
lui effectivement on vous l'avait dit
a dit espérer trouver une solution tout
en accusant des embauches hinton
d'utiliser l'ukraine comme un instrument
pour entraîner moscou dans un conflit
armé votre analyse oui je pense que je
pense que il a raison c'est à dire que
l'idée en fait alors pas forcément de
tout de tout va dire l'état à l'état
américain moi je pense que byron
aimerait bien régler le problème avec la
russie pour pouvoir passer à autre chose
et s'occuper de la chine mais je pense
qu'il y encore toute une partie de
l'establishment américain notamment sans
doute les services secrets une partie du
pentagone qui eux aimeraient bien aller
jusqu'au bout et pour ça en fait c'est
provoquer une intervention russe dans le
donbass en organisant une opération
militaire est d'ailleurs il ya on
observe du côté ukrainien une
accumulation de matériel d'une
accumulation
de personnel moi je pense que ça n'ira
pas jusque là parce que céline ce qui
n'a pas reçu le feu vert de joe biden
pour le faire je pense conclut céline ce
qui lui-même a compris que son économie
ne peut plus permettre cette situation
ils ont déjà perdu officiellement 13 5
milliards de dollars à cause de cette
situation de tension et de toute manière
l'armée ukrainienne n'est même pas
certaine de l'emporter contre les les
armes et des républiques de donetsk est
lougansk tout seul c'est à dire que elle
peut perdre la guerre avant même que la
russie interviennent et les armes qui
ont été donnés d'ailleurs on a souvent
parlé ce sont des armes antichars de
courte portée ce sont 6 bayraktar donc
ces fameux drones mais on assiste donc
ça ne changera pas le rapport de forces
sur le front donc effectivement devenir
poutine a raison qu'une partie de
l'establishment eux mêmes non seulement
américaines et occidentales aimerait
pousser la russie à intervenir pour
mettre une vague de sanctions si tant
est qu'ils osent mettre ces sanctions il
ya plus grand chose à mettre comme
sanction et la russie est largement
capable de tenir face à une telle menace
d'autant plus qu'elle va recevoir non
seulement soutien de la chine mais du
brésil le vice-président brésilien vient
de
déclarer que la russie était légitime à
vouloir garantir sa sécurité à ses
frontières dernière question vous aviez
moreau poutine
est clair que les états unis et l'otan
avaient choisi jusqu'ici d'ignorer les
préoccupations russes on regarde de sa
sécurité aujourd'hui ou qu'elles peuvent
être justement les options que peut
prendre que peuvent prendre la russie
la première option c'est de continuer
les négociations ce sur quoi washington
et moscou sont d'accord et dans le pire
des cas et bien c'est de rejouer la
crise des missiles de cuba c'est à dire
que ça a été évoqué je crois par vice
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
qui a dit qu'il ne s'interdisait pas
pourquoi pas d'aller mettre des missiles
à cuba au venezuela et puis et puis ça
finira comme la crise de cuba c'est à
dire que les russes retireront leurs
missiles de cuba en échange qui à
l'époque les les américains avaient
retiré leurs missiles de turquie leurs
missiles le jupiter donc je pense qu'on
va un peu dans une situation comme ça je
pense aussi qu'il ya quelque chose se
prépare avec la chine on verra
rapidement dans quelques jours avec
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques est la
rencontre entre saint jean ping et
lanières poutine mais je pense que c'est
tout cet empressement de la russie a
demandé dès des garanties écrites je
pense que c'est aussi pour préparer
quelque chose de manière formelle avec
la chine cette idée d'un juriste à la
base donc ils aiment bien que les choses
soient soient posées sur le papier ils
ne croient plus aux promesses et il a
bien raison entre d'entre nous merci
beaucoup mais saviez moreau d'avoir été
avec nous et nous avoir apporté votre
analyse
dans le reste de l'actualité un rapport
d'amnesty international qui fait
polémique les ong qualifie d' apartheid
la politique d'israël envers les
palestiniens et les arabes israéliens
des propos similaires à ceux tenus par
d'autres organisations qui provoque la
colère d or et aidé les autorités
israéliennes les précisions de françois
xavier de lambert
bridonneau après avoir utilisé pour la
première fois le terme d'apartheid abc
internationale persiste et signe dans un
nouveau rapport l'eau est j'aimais
durban en cause l'état hébreu qui
traiterait selon elle les palestiniens
comme un groupe racial inférieur lors
d'une conférence de presse à jérusalem
les représentants de l'organisation ont
décrit la mise en place d'un d'apartheid
institutionnalisée l'apartheid est à la
fois un système est un crime comme
l'interdît le droit international un
système d'apartheid et un régime
institutionnalisée d'oppression et de
domination d'un groupe racial sur un
autre imposé par des lois des politiques
et des pratiques
ces accusation suscite la colère des
autorités israéliennes
hier le ministre des affaires étrangères
de l'état hébreu a demandé amnesty de
retirer son rapport il dénonce une
propagande antisémite décidé à
diaboliser israël
au lieu de rechercher la vérité amnesty
fait écho aux mêmes mensonges partagé
par les organisations terroristes
cinq minutes d'examen sérieux suffirait
pour savoir que les soi disant fait du
rapport publié par amnesty cette semaine
son délirant et déconnectés de la
réalité
à l'opposé de la réaction israélienne
les palestiniens se sont réjouis de la
publication de ce rapport
l'autorité palestinienne qui contrôle
une partie de la cisjordanie occupée
salut notamment au travail courageux et
jus de son côté le hamas au pouvoir dans
la bande de gaza loue le
professionnalisme d'amnesty
international mais la publication de ce
rapport a aussi des conséquences sur le
plan juridique les ong demandent
notamment à la cour pénale
internationale d'ajouter le crime
d'apartheid aux accusations qui pèsent
sur l'état hébreu suite à l'ouverture
d'une enquête liée à la politique
israélienne à l'égard des palestiniens
des procédures qui inquiète israël la
diplomatie de l'état hébreu tente de
rallier des pays occidentaux à sa cause
pour éviter une condamnation
la sphère julian assange au centre des
débats en france une proposition de loi
du groupe liberté et territoires suggère
d'accorder l'asile au fondateur de
wikileaks julian assange est détenu
depuis près de trois ans dans une prison
britannique il reste sous le coup d'une
extradition aux états unis après avoir
diffusé des documents classifiés le
texte indique que le gouvernement
français lui est accordée à l'asie
politique et de manière plus générale à
faciliter l'accès au statut de réfugié
pour les lanceurs d'alertés étrangers il
est notamment soutenu par les députés
françois ruffin et cédric villani
il s'agit que ça soit pas oublié il
s'agit que cette histoire elle passe pas
sous le tapis comme si de rien n'était
je le redis pour moi il en va de la
liberté d'un homme c'est les droits de
l'homme c'est un homme dont le
rapporteur de l'onu dit qu'aujourd'hui
il est persécuté torturé et qu'il faut
en finir immédiatement écrit-il avec ça
il y va de la liberté de la presse pour
la première fois à l'assemblée nationale
est inscrit à l'ordre du jour le sort de
julian assange
lanceur dallaire prisonniers politiques
et ce sera l'occasion d'aborder les
facettes de ce dossier emblématique
niveau des lanceurs d'alert un dossier
qui relève des droits humains de ces qui
relève de la liberté de la presse un
dossier qui relève de jeu politique la
politique en france avec le
rassemblement national bien en
difficulté et réunion demain soir par
visioconférence à la demande
sa candidate à la présidentielle marine
le pen convoque l'ensemble des instances
de son parti après la multiplication des
défections et départ que certains
expliquent par l'infléchissement de la
patronne du fn sur certains sujets
yamanouchi
marine ce n'est pas jean-marie mais ce
n'est pas non plus la marine d'il ya
cinq ans en tout cas ce ne sont plus
exactement les mêmes propositions alors
la candidate et rennes ne s'est pas
transformé en bolchévique antispécistes
mais certaines de ses positions ou tout
de même évolué et notamment sur l'europe
rappelez vous fin en 2017 en toute
première place des 144 engagements
présidentiels 2 marine le pen on
trouvait ceci retrouver notre liberté la
maîtrise de notre destin en restituant
peuple français sa souveraineté pour
cela une négociation sera engagée avec
nos partenaires européens suivi d'un
référendum sur notre appartenance à
l'union européenne désormais plus de
fric site mais plutôt une modification
de la hiérarchie des normes françaises
j'inscris la supériorité du droit
constitutionnel sur le droit européen
je fait voter par les français une
modification constitutionnelle
indiquant que tous les textes européens
qui sont contraires à notre loi suprême
c'est à dire notre constitution non pas
d'application dans le droit interne
français plus de sortie de l'europe et
donc pas d'abandon de l'euro non plus
mais une réforme de l'intérieur des
institutions et de la monnaie de l'union
autre renoncement la suppression de la
double nationalité
extra-européenne c'était une mesure du
programme de marine le pen en 2017
contraindre les français également
citoyen d'un autre pays extra-européens
à choisir l'une des deux nationalités il
n'en est plus question aujourd'hui j'ai
rencontré des milliers de gens par
exemple des marocains qui juridiquement
ne peuvent renoncer à leur nationalité
car leur pays l'interdît honnêtement je
préfère mettre ça de côté car c'est
comme mettre du sel sur des plaies
ouvertes
marine le pen conserve toutefois comme
il ya cinq ans la suppression du droit
du sol côté sociétal là aussi quelques
changements la candidate frontiste d'il
ya cinq ans souhaitait notamment abroger
la loi taubira sur le mariage pour tous
est instauré à la place un pacs
améliorée aujourd'hui cette proposition
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour en tout cas
pas à l'ordre du jour des premières
années de son hypothétique mandat je
mettrai en place une forme de moratoire
pendant trois ans sur tous les sujets
j'ai sociétaux parce que je pense que la
société française n'a pas besoin de
fracturation supplémentaires dans le
même temps je veux mettre en place un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
ceux qui souhaitent revenir sur des lois
ils réuniront cinq cent mille signatures
et il y aura un référendum organisé sur
ces sujets pour que la société réponde
aux sujets de société on peut enfin
noter un durcissement vis-à-vis de
l'éolien que marine le pen souhaitent
démanteler tout comme elle compte cesser
de subventionner le solaire bref il y a
donc eu des évolutions entre les
programmes de 2017 et 2022 et d'autres
pourraient encore survenir alors
certains d'entre vous peuvent se dire
qu'il s'agit là de changements à la
marge et bien détrompez-vous nombre des
sujets que je viens de lister sont des
marqueurs puissant au sein de
l'électorat nationaliste il n'est pas
impossible qu'ils aient participé à
pousser certains des proches de la
candidate du rassemblement national à
rejoindre son rival éric zemmour un
paradoxe après tant d'années passées par
la fille de jean marie le pen à se
dédiaboliser devenu plus fréquentable
marine le pen en perd ses fréquentations
marine le pen qui peine à réunir les 500
signatures d'élus pour participer à la
présidentielle aujourd'hui le conseil
constitutionnel a publié la première
partie des parrainages reçus et validés
par l'institution les candidats du
rassemblement national compte pour
l'heure que de parrainage emmanuel
macron lui est en tête de ce premier
point d'étape avec 105 signature le
président sortant qui pourtant tarder à
officialiser sa candidature on en parle
tout de suite avec alexis poulain
bonsoir
et c'est lors de votre édito alexis
bonsoir emmanuel macron qui donc et on
visite un dans le nord demain puis
d'autres déplacements de prévu un
président clairement campagne sur le
terrain mais en tout cas quelle est sa
fenêtre de tir pour sa candidature c'est
un petit peu la question tout le monde
se pose
oui c'est sûr alors emmanuel macron ça
rime avec caméléon demain il est sur les
terres du nord pour se recueillir sur
les mines les mineurs bien sûr alors que
sa politique a bénéficié aux plus riches
depuis cinq ans mais il n'est pas à une
contradiction près et d'ailleurs avec
ses nombreux costumes qu'il a pu
endosser il endosse à la fois le costume
de président et il a du mal à choisir
celui de candidat c'est vrai d'autres
déplacements sont encore prévues même si
tout est flou dans l'agenda présidentiel
donc on attend de savoir comment et
quand mêmes macron va se déclarer
candidat lui souhaite le faire d'une
manière assez désinvolte pour ne pas
officialiser finalement sa candidature
et garder une stature présidentielle qui
bat est tout à fait dans son intérêt il
est à la fois prises dans la réplique
française président aussi de l'union
européenne pendant quelques mois ci qui
fait qu'il est au dessus de la mêlée
d'une certaine façon d'ailleurs ses
porte paroles comme gabriel at-elle on
dit que il n'y avait aucune raison pour
qu'ils veulent mâcon participent à un
débat du premier tour c'est étonnant
quand même pour un candidat sortant qui
souhaitent sa réélection d'autres
candidats ont joué la carte et la montre
c'était le cas de jacques chirac de
nicolas sarkozy aussi de faire des
campagnes éclair parce que ça permet
d'aller vite d'éviter aussi de défendre
son bilan trop long trop longuement
parce que comme je le disais ce bilan
finalement bien ils ne bénéficient pas
de à tous les français loin de là alors
au delà du timing de l'annoncé qui ne
fait plus aucun doute quel bilan
à défendre alexis pour emmanuel macron
parce qu'il a des sondages des non
satisfait le chômage des jeunes
sacrifiés 300 mort du duc hobbit pas
vraiment de réforme de retraites le
pouvoir d'achat qui grince bon bref
c'est pas très joyeux pour l'instant il
ya des choses à défendre
c'est celle qui est compliqué alors et
il défend des le pass culture sur
minable c'est vrai que c'est une bonne
mesure mais si on regarde en détail ce
quinquennat c'est un échec un échec à la
fois économique on a les chiffres du
chômage qui sont à peu près les mêmes
qu'en 2012 au moment où françois
hollande a tenté la version de la courbe
du chômage on a une croissance à -1 1%
même si tout le monde dit qu'on est à +
7 % en réalité on rattrape le choc qui a
été le confinement du coc vides et les
moins 8% de croissance on a une dette
faramineuse la dette qu'ovide là aussi
comment la rembourser ça va être très
compliqué et puis on a 300 morts du coït
par jour et mme nasles macron veut les
faire oublier avec le pass vaccinale et
dire que finalement au micron c'est un
petit virus c'est qu'on va continuer de
vivre comme avant surtout surtout ne pas
mentionner le nombre de morts quotidiens
du coc vide ou avec le co vide et puis
il y à tous les déçus de la politique
macro nist pendant cinq ans 67% des
français qui s'estiment perdants des
politiques mises en place par abonné le
maquereau c'est le dernier sondage ifop
fiducial
ils étaient 73 % il ya quelques mois et
on voit bien que le pouvoir d'achat est
bien il a stagné voire il a diminué pour
de nombreux français malgré l'échec
énergie malgré les petits cadeaux pour
essayer de gagner des élections que fait
madame accroc depuis des semaines il
fait des cadeaux des promesses des
chèques en blanc avec l'argent des
français pour finalement assurer une
réélection avec cet argent parce que lui
en tant que président peut se permettre
ces largesses la réalité c'est un pays
endetté c'est un pays qui ne sait pas
finalement si l'économie va se relever
de ses politique délétère face au co
vide et c'est un président qui a fait
gagner les plus riches des français est
certainement pas tous les français donc
aujourd'hui ça me paraît un bilan
difficilement défendable y compris pour
ses fans de la première heure parce
qu'il était celui qui apportait les
réformes la réforme des retraites elle
n'a pas eu lieu il ya eu la réforme de
l'assurance-chômage poussé in fine et
par la ministre du travail mais on voit
qu'ils émanaient de maquereau qui
promettait un nouveau monde finalement a
fait le pire de l'ancien monde avec des
conflits d'intérêts à la chaîne des
mises en examen finalement un monde
politique aussi délétère que celui
d'avant on a l'impression que c'est un
échec et pourtant tous ceux présents
pour lui de la meilleure des façons avec
des médias qui le pousse dans les
sondages disons que c'est le meilleur
président que la france ait jamais connu
loin s'en fout alors avec alexis le en
même temps c'est ray manuel macron
n'est-il pas aidé par les divisions des
camps de droite et de gauche quand même
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a une chose qui
facilite la campagne non encore
officiels déballer le maquereau c'est la
division des camps en présence que ce
soit le camp de gauche avec une nouvelle
candidate qui vient d'arriver christiane
taubira bravo à elle mais ça fait
beaucoup de candidats à gauche et le
camp de droite divisée entre valérie
pécresse les républicains eric zemmour
et marine le pen trois candidats aussi
sur un segment qui pourraient se
regrouper lui mnm maquereau a la chance
d'être au centre et de tenir ce centre
de manière hégémonique même si edouard
philippe attend son heure avec horizons
avec cette maison commune qui va
transformer en marche dans un nouveau
mouvement avec vous cinquante plus tout
est fait pour effacer le nom en marche
pour effacer le nom et menait macron
pour effacer le bilan finalement et
faire en sorte que ce président caméléon
comme je le disais en introduction peut
continuer va continuer à être le tenant
finalement de ce camp du centre qui peut
faire tout et n'importe quoi y compris
des politiques liberticides où les
devoirs sont supérieurs aux droits ou le
pass vaccinale anticonstitutionnel est
imposé aux français où les étudiants ont
été obligés de faire la queue pour se
nourrir devant les banque alimentaire
alors que lui se gargarise finalement de
sa politique sur le pass culture et
quelques détails technocratique mais la
réalité de ce quinquennat de cinq ans
c'est une division des français comme
jamais c'est un pays fracturée c'est un
pays aussi inquiet avec des suscite chez
les jeunes comme on n'en a jamais vu
avec des français aussi qui en ont marre
de cette politique ou et melba kron veux
emmerder une portion de la population
jusqu'au bout je crois que pour lui
cette candidature est pourquoi il l'a
recul c'est que finalement il sera face
à un miroir et face à ce miroir c'est le
vote des français et peut-être que là il
aura du mal à changer de costume et
c'est l édito d'alexis poulain merci à
vous ou alexis
rester avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des ehpad et orpea les
hésitants subirait des conditions
d'accueil dégradantes un scandale dont
se saisit l'exécutif jean caces promet
d'agir de ne pas rester inactif face à
ces accusations présumé la ministre
chargée de l'autonomie des personnes
âgées annonce l'ouverture de deux
enquêtes administratives
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et la population
africaine c'est un milliard d'habitants
c'est ça à la valeur de nos krypton
mener
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement qu'en ce
cas ci nous parce que l'argent liquide
perd de la valeur beaucoup de pays en
afrique ont interdit la crypto est ce
que vous répondez à cela d'une canette
on ne peut pas dire on va interdire la
crypto temps qu'il ya internet il y aura
des crypto
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçus
mais pas surpris
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes
semblent s'être octroyé un pouvoir de
juger à pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens j'ai
cherché j'ai essayé de trouver des
réponses mais émettra 20 suis jamais à
oger mon qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio c'est
si c'est grave ou si c'est pas grave
plus qu'à la télé
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
il est 21h ma ci ne rejoigne pour cette
deuxième partie d'émission au sommaire
en france les épaves et particulièrement
au pea dans la tourmente les résidents
subirait des conditions d'accueil
dégradantes un scandale dont se saisit
l'exécutif jean castex promet d'agir de
ne pas rester inactif face à ces
accusations présumés deux enquêtes
administratives sont ouvertes pdg lan
sera lui auditionné demain par les
députés alors la france traite telma les
personnes âgées on ouvre le débat et on
attend vos réactions sur le compte et
des grappes d'ayrté france
[Musique]
des repas ou des soins d'hygiène
rationné le groupe privées orpea est
accusée de maltraitance envers les
résidents de ces et pas deux enquêtes
ont été lancées par le gouvernement on
en parle avec notre reporter lucas léger
en direct depuis le ministère de la
santé bonsoir le cas aujourd'hui la
ministre chargée de l'autonomie des
personnes âgées a convoqué donc les
dirigeants un d'orpea mis en cause
qu'est ce qui ressort de ces entretiens
et bien elle a publié un communiqué peu
après cette rencontre a expliqué qu'elle
avait dit son indignation devant les
révélations de ce livre les fossoyeurs
du journaliste victor castanet elle
précise aussi qu'elle a écouté ce que ce
qu'on dit ses dirigeants à savoir le
directeur général qui est là depuis
quelques jours philippe charrier et le
directeur général france jean-christophe
remercie et elle les a informés de la
tenue de deux enquêtes l'une de
l'inspection générale des affaires
sociales et l'autre de l'inspection
générale des finances il y aura aussi
des contrôles dans les établissements du
groupe enfin elle consultera les les
familles les élus départementaux et les
acteurs du de ceux de ce milieu pour que
plus jamais ce genre de chose ne puisse
se produire à la promis des solutions
d'ici fin février et jean castex s'est
exprimé devant les députés sur ce
scandale je vous propose d'écouter ce
qu'il a dit
nous avons tous été sur tous les bords
fortement interpellé par les accusations
extrêmement graves
qui ont été portées contre le le groupe
orpea et les pratiques à l'endroit des
résidents et je veux si vous me
permettez
d'emblée manifesté ma
compassion et ma solidarité à l'endroit
des résidents et des familles qui ont
été les victimes de ses agissements
la ministre brigitte bourguignon vous le
savez a convoqué vous l'avez dit les
dirigeants de ce groupe
aujourd'hui même et je le dis à la
représentation nationale
nous l'entendons évidemment pas rester
inactif face à ces accusations présumé
et lucas prochaine étape audition par
les députés du pdg d'orpea
absolument il va être entendu par les
députés de la commission des affaires
sociales de l'assemblée nationale demain
et il pourrait même y avoir une
commission d' enquête parlementaire
c'est une
possibilité ce pdg après sa rencontre
avec la ministre s'est exprimé devant
les journalistes et je vous propose
d'écouter ce qu'il a dit nous comprenons
parfaitement l'émotion
des résidants des familles et des
collaborateurs à l'égard de ce qu'ils
peuvent lire et nous nous engageons dans
la transparence dans une totale
indépendance à faire la totale lumière
sur ces événements ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que ce que nous avons lu ne
correspond absolument pas à la réalité
de la vie dans nos établissements
nous avons mandaté deux cabinets
extérieurs pour faire toute la lumière
une nouvelle fois madame la ministre
nous a dit qu'elle allait faire des
inspections des contrôles et nous sommes
très heureux d'avoir ces inspections et
ses contrôles
d'ores et déjà nous savons que plusieurs
accusations sont infondées j'en ai la
preuve la preuve formelle documentaire
je vous demande qu'une seule chose au
nom des 70 mille collaborateurs qui
travaillent dans une société dans 23
pays dans le monde la seule chose que je
vous demande ne nous accusez pas avant
de nous avoir jugé aujourd'hui très
nettement nous sommes accusés et on n'a
pas été vue est à noter que en plus des
enquêtes administratives orpea pourrait
faire face à la justice puisque les
familles des résidents veulent faire une
action collective conjointe leurs
avocats devant lancer une procédure pour
homicide involontaire mise en danger
délibérée de la vie d'autrui violence
par négligence ou non assistance à
personne en danger merci lucas allégée
de ces précisions et la maltraitance un
de nos aînés dans les ehpad fait
beaucoup réagir ces dernières heures
pourtant aucun gouvernement n'a pris de
mesures concrètes et cela depuis le plan
de villepin présenté en 2006 et un
attentisme qui fait débat pour un sujet
épineux qui s'invite dans la campagne
présidentielle
on fait le point avec tony pitaro
augmenter le nombre de soignants inventé
la maison de retraite de demain
insuffler une nouvelle dynamique et 500
millions d'euros d'investissements
c'était le plan de solidarité grand âge
de dominique de villepin en 2006 seize
ans après la situation dans les ehpad
n'a cessé de se dégrader une véritable
maltraitance institutionnelle
dénoncées par le personnel soignant tu
pas que vous devez
rationner un plat pour un résident qui a
travaillé toute sa vie et qui paye 8000
euros une chambre par mois je trouve ça
scandaleux
un temps ne peut pas lui changer sa
couche est plus de trois fois par jour
c'est de l'aberration on peut pas
continuer comme ça ça suffit c'est de la
maltraitance des témoignages confirmés
par la défenseure des droits claire
hédon qui a publié en 2021 un rapport à
destination des pouvoirs publics mettre
systématiquement des couches aux
résidents alors que certains ne sont pas
en continent les heures de repas de
lever et de coucher fixé en fonction de
la disponibilité de personnel et non pas
dans le respect du rythme de vie des
personnes âgées des douches une seule
fois par semaine des situations très
concrètes de non respect des droits et
de la dignité des personnes est
clairement ses atteintes aux droits
fondamentaux sont rendues possibles
parce qu'en face se trouve des personnes
vulnérables en 2003 suite à la canicule
et à l'émotion nationale provoque et
jacques chirac avait créé la journée de
solidarité afin de financer la mise aux
normes de ce qu'on appelait encore les
maisons de retraite mais il faudra
attendre 2016 et françois hollande pour
voir apparaître des mesures plus ample
porté par marisol touraine la loi
relative à l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement dite loi as v entendait
mobiliser l'ensemble des politiques
publiques vers un meilleur
accompagnement des personnes âgées un
voeu pieux puisque la loi confiaient en
grande partie aux acteurs locaux a connu
des applications très inégale selon les
zones géographiques
depuis aucune mesure de taille n'a été
prise le sujet n'a pas été au centre du
débat ces dernières années avec des
aidants qui manquent notamment de
considération et de soutien de la part
des gouvernements
au niveau européen la france ne se place
qu'à la quatrième position avec
seulement 1,32 pour cent du pib investi
l'hexagone est ainsi derrière la norvège
la suède et des pays bas la récente
polémique suscitée par les
établissements pea a sans doute permis
au sujet un éclairage opportun en pleine
campagne présidentielle
reste à voir si le sujet survivra aux
prochaines échéances électorales et pour
en parler nous sommes avec florence haye
et fondatrice de l'association victoria
aide aux personnes vulnérables bonsoir
madame merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
nous apportez votre témoignage en direct
sur rt france on a entendu le pdg dans
perdirent ne nous accusez pas avant
d'avoir été jugé
e que lui répondez vous
bien c'est difficile parce que nous
familles ou constate au énormément de
l'isf fonctionnement dans les ai pas
parce que nous malheureusement nous
sommes dans l'obligation de placer un
autre parent et lorsque nous nous
rendons fréquemment
visitez notre parent on ne peut que
constater les dysfonctionnements les
situations de maltraitance
donc voilà les manquements graves les
maintenant à la sécurité la non
assistance à personne en danger tout ça
je les ai vécus et tout ça je peux en
témoigner puisque ma mère a quand même
fréquenté deux ehpad donc dans le var à
raison de trois ans pour chaque ehpad et
dans chaque est pas 2,5 et la
catastrophe et des constats alarmants
des constats désastreux de mauvaise
prise en charge de manière un cas vécu
des situations très difficiles des
chutes à répétition au désensablement
dans la chambre parce qu'elle était un
peu énervé donc dans le noir avec une
chaleur épouvantable puisque nous étions
en était qu'il n'y avait pas de
climatisation dans la chambre elle hurle
elle appelé au secours et voilà il était
seul voilà comment j'ai pu retrouver ma
mère mais j'ai pu aussi voir des
résidents perdu dans le jardin faut
savoir que dans une dans un dépanneur
jardin était excentré par rapport à la
pièce de vie et donc les résidents
partait dans ce jardin les soignants ne
les voyait pas forcément et donc qu'il
restait dans ce jardin en plein soleil
parce que c'était les clés personnes de
venir les voir mais voilà il avait
eu une était pas protéger du soleil
n'avait pas à boire et ils combien de
fois je suis venu en aide voilà ses
résidents je les ai milan sécurité pour
certains je suis cas dans le jardin il
n'y avait personne pour la surveiller
enfin voila j'ai aussi vécu une
situation d' attouchements sexuels dans
un les ehpad que ma mère a fréquenté jeu
les dénoncer à la rs notamment donc à
travers des courriers que j'ai pu
envoyer j'ai fait une une dénonciation
auprès du procureur de la république qui
est resté sans suite auprès de la rs
rien n'a changé
c'était madame excusez moi parce que je
reste un petit peu sans voix de ce
témoignage vous avez donc fait une un
signalement l ars qui vous a rien
répondu les choses n'ont pas changé
les gasy l'engrais pour moi il ya eu une
enquête
alors je crois bien que oui puisque un
personnel avec qui je m'entendais très
bien la bdic unis un jour il y avait eu
des inspecteurs qui était venu et c'est
kara mais pour autant je et j'ai vu
quelques améliorations très légère
amélioration
et puis par la suite tout a repris voilà
en situation de
dysfonctionnements fin à nouveau j'ai
constaté les problèmes à nouveau j'ai
constaté que la personne qui a exercé
les attouchements sexuels donc un
résident qui était lui même atteint de
maladie d'alzheimer continuer à exercer
ces violences sexuelles sur des
résidentes qui était âgée de 80 85 90
ans donc que des dames qui était entré
dans cet ehpad qui quand même
dont on peut penser que vont elles
allaient être en sécurité protégé par la
direction est en fait ce n'était pas le
cas et tours évidemment je dirais la
totalité d'entre elles ne les avait
jamais connu de violence sexuelle il
fallait qu'ils entrent dans un débat
pour connaître ça et on n'a rien fait
c'était au vu et au su de tout le
personnel le voyez mes gamins santé le
voyez la directrice le voyez les
familles quand elles veulent est pouvez
le constater aussi donc et voilà une
personne n'a rien fait j'ai dénoncé les
faits et pourtant rien n'a changé ça a
continué voilà c'est extrêmement
évidemment solidaire organisé deux
soirées je suis outré charme qu'on n'est
pas
qu'on ne soit pas intervenu que les
autorités de tutelle n'ai rien fait je
les déclarer voilà je pense que bon il
faut aussi croire les femmes ils ne font
pas ça pour leur plaisir à fond ça pour
le bien être déjà de leurs proches et
puis aussi des résidents qui sont dans
le même immeuble dans lequel est placé
un membre de sa famille donc voilà
entre famille justement puisque vous
faites partie d'un collectif comment
vous nous expliquer ça est-ce que vous
avez des pistes vont qui connaissait
bien malheureusement ce ce sujet
alors on a essayé de créer des
collectifs notamment dans l'autre et
fallou été ma mère mais on s'aperçoit
qu'il est très difficile de rassembler
les familles parce qu'elle lui disent
qu'elles ont peur qu'on s'en prenne à
leurs parents ils ont peur des
représailles
elles ne veulent pas porter plainte à ce
qu'elle constate des manquements graves
manquements graves à la sécurité
charles haas a concerné plusieurs
domaines et elles n'osent pas porter
plainte elles n'osent pas à contacter
les autorités de tutelle parfois elle ne
les connaissent même pas le sable a pas
que ça existe et du coup
les problèmes
enfin on veut continuer à exister ou
salées des ehpad et on aura beaucoup de
mal à faire bouger les familles qui se
plaignent important mais qui finalement
ne vont pas aller au delà voilà je
dirais qu'ils vont vraiment des craintes
à agir voilà au delà de ça florence et y
est vous avez entendu le premier
ministre aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nous
dire voilà on va prendre le problème à
bras le corps vous le croyez qu'est ce
que vous attendez aujourd'hui du
gouvernement
bien qu'une prise en considération des
personnes âgées lorsqu'elles sont
placées on n'est pas qu'on leur accorde
du respect qu'on entend surtout les
familles puisque de toute façon les
familles sont les porte parole l'un des
résidents en ehpad puisque bien souvent
pour la plupart elles ont des
difficultés à exprimer faire le bal être
les situations de maltraitance aux
fins dont elles sont victimes
donc c'est cesser les familles qui
doivent
rapporter tout ce qui se passe on n'est
pas des qui doivent se faire le porte
parole de la proche de la paire de leur
mère et on ne doit pas les laisser
souffrir enfin et vivre les dernières
années de leur vie dans de telles
conditions voilà et surtout moi je ne
pas que jean ka-52 devrait quand même
assister les autorités de tutelle à
entendre les familles lorsqu'elles se
plaignent est allé vérifier contrôler
les ehpad lorsqu'il y à des
dénonciations tels que j'ai pu faire
j'en ai fait les dénonciations parce que
ma mère dans le second et padoue a lutté
elle est victime d'une fracture de
l'épaule que personne n'a relevé c'est
moi la polémique est constaté que ma
mère avec mal moi et j'ai en effet car
la fia mère je mets du oui mon bon on va
pas l'envoyer aux urgences pour ça on
voyait pas parce qu'elle avait un gilet
et donc je suis parti en fin d'après
midi la mère m'a appelé vers ce qu'on
avait les habiller votre maman lorsqu'on
la mise en chemise de nuit on s'est
rendu compte qu'elle avait le moral bleu
noir et c'est pourquoi avoir urgence et
lorsque je suis arrivé aux urgences j'ai
vu le médecin dentiste qui m'a dit
écoutez votre mère a fait une chute et
lorsque j'ai
reçu entretenu donc avec le directeur du
ballet il m'a dit ah ben non votre mère
n'a pas fait de chutes et personne nous
a relaté que votre maman avait fait une
chute de ma mère était complètement
impotente un état incapable icv elle
était vraiment au bout de sa vie voilà
invité à la merci des aides-soignants
donc pas là donc c'est certainement le
fait d'une maladresse d'un manquement à
la sécurité de la part d'un soignant qui
a fait que ma mère est tombée
probablement son lit le matin voilà
lorsqu'il a pris en charge pour la
toilette qui l'a remise sur son fauteuil
et qu'il a laissé comme ça donc il ya
une ombre assistance à personne en
danger j'ai porté plainte auprès du
commissariat de police et pour autant il
n'y a pas eu de suite et quand je me
suis adressé ma fille me dit ça je suis
dit mais il coûte voilà ce qui s'est
passé à dubaï bien sûr que c'est une que
c'est qu'une chute ça peut pas être dû à
autre chose qu'à une chute
donc voilà donc pour tout le monde et
lorsque je me suis adressé au chirurgien
qui avait opéré ma mère il m'a dit
évidemment que c'est dû à une chute
donc voila et quand j'ai engrangé le
médecin coordonnateur de l'ehpad et le
directeur ils m'ont tous les deux dit
que cette élite fractures spontanées qui
n'existe pas en tous les cas pour les
membres supérieurs sont toutes manières
ne servait plus de ces moelleux salé
pionnière merci en tout cas florent
soyez pour ce témoignage
voilà émouvant et disons le est
extrêmement choquant un merci à jean en
tout cas d'avoir d'avoir témoigné sur
l'antenne d'arte et france est un
scandale orpea qui pourrait peut-être en
révéler d'autres la france traite elle
mal ces personnes âgées en attend vos
réactions sur notre compte télégramme
place à notre décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler rite revel
éditorialistes rt france bonsoir et
revel merci beaucoup d'être avec nous à
vos côtés jacques myard un mer et l'air
de maisons laffitte alors c'est vrai
qu'on vient d'entendre ce reportage
assez accablant et qui nous a mis un peu
mal à l'aise il faut bien le dire sur ce
plateau de florence haye et qui parlait
de ça sa maman qui a été victime de deux
maltraitance dans deux ehpad votre
réaction chaque milliard
écoutez vous savez il faut prendre ça
avec sérieux il faut prendre ça avec
rigueur il faut écouter il peut y avoir
effectivement ce que madame maillet a
rapporté des maltraitances c'est vrai
moi même j'ai fait fermer une maison de
retraite où les patients étaient sanglés
dans leurs lits et nous l'avons fermé et
la société a disparu ça peut
parfaitement arriver mais il faut se
garder je dirais de généraliser car j'ai
sur ma ville
quatre ou cinq résidence ehpad et je
n'ai pas de plainte il y en a eu je
viens de vous le rappeler il y a
quelques années ça remonte déjà à 7 8
ans mais aujourd'hui nous veillons et
nous sommes extrêmement attachés ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il va pas y avoir un
problème demain mais ce que vient de
rapporter mal à maillet est extrêmement
choquant cela va de soi et donc je crois
qu'il s'est tu savais je vous dire cent
fois sur le métier remettre l'ouvragé on
n'est sûr de rien on peut avoir demain
matin des plaintes sur une parce que il
ya un manquement parce qu'il ya du
personnel qui ne veut pas dire qu'il
s'est trompé et sa part en quenouille
donc il faut être extrêmement prudent
alors deux enquêtes en tout cas on est
est ouvert ce matin par le gouvernement
le pdg d'orpea sera auditionné demain
par les députés cet après-midi le
scandale était évidemment au centre de
la séance de questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale je vous propose
d'écouter notamment andré chassaigne
député communiste qui a interpellé au
gouvernement
les faits sont gravissimes pour autant
cette affaire ne doit pas être l'arbre
qui cache la forêt il existe un autre
pays une maltraitance structurelle de
nos aînés qui interroge des politiques
conduites en matière de dépendance
depuis 30 ans en dépit des plans
gouvernementaux successifs les
financements publics n'ont pas été au
rendez vous ils ne le sont pas non plus
depuis cinq ans alors que les
professionnels ne cessent de vous
alerter sur un taux d'encadrement
insuffisant sur des conditions de
travail dégradées sur leurs difficultés
à prendre en charge dignement les
personnes âgées qu'ils accueillent c'est
sur ce terrain propice que ce
s'engouffre une poignée de grands
groupes avec la bénédiction des pouvoirs
publics ils représentent désormais 20%
des places en ehpad et dégagent
d'énormes bénéfices sur le dos des
salariés et des usagers
eric revel andré chassaigne qui qui
pointe du doigt plusieurs problèmes un
déjà de la maltraitance structurelle à
répétition et surtout l'impuissance et
l'incompétence quasiment des
gouvernements successifs
est-ce qu'ils pointent tout simplement
un scandale d'état
écouter tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant d'abord évidemment il faut
il faut rendre hommage à ce témoignage
qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure parce que
toute situation particulière de ce
niveau de maltraitances sans doute nous
touche directement parce que on a
probablement tous une grand mère peut
être une mère peut être un nom ou une
tante qui qui sont dans ce genre
d'établissement donc évidemment on a un
rapport à ce secteur de la dépendance et
des résidences seniors qui est tout à
fait partie humain puisque par
définition on est touchés on sera touché
par par ce genre de choses et quand on
entend ces témoignages évidemment on ne
peut que s'inquiéter mais ce que
j'aimerais répondre au député chassaigne
c'est que quand il dit qu'il ya 20 % des
lits qui appartient des groupes privés
ça veut dire que le restant n'appartient
pas à des groupes privés c'est à dire
que en france il faut le savoir il ya 6
% de la population de plus de 65 ans qui
réside dans ce type d'établissement ça
concerne 7 128 mille personnes dans
notre pays et environ dix mille 600
établissements mais ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que 50% des ehpad son public
d'abord première chose son public
monsieur chassaigne l'a oubliée donc
public bas ça dépend de l'état des
financements de l'état et du contrôle de
l'état sur le restant qui est privé vous
en avez 30 31 % de ces ehpad qui sont
privées certes mais à but non lucratif
qui sont gérés par des associations donc
on se dit c'est pas la course aux
dividendes et au profit capitaliste tel
que le décrit monsieur chassaigne et
enfin effectivement il ya 24 % de
groupes privés qui versent des
dividendes à leurs actionnaires mais qui
ne sont que 20 24% dans la totalité des
100 % que présente ce type de résidence
donc pardonnez-moi mais vouloir en faire
une sorte de procès politique de
récupération politique sur un sujet
outil aussi sensible qui nous touche
autant encore une fois parce qu'on a une
grand mère parce qu'on est maire parce
qu'on a un nom que l'on tende qu'on va
voir le week-end et qu'on n'oublie pas à
l'autre panne d'offres à le bout de la
france c'est un peu un peu petit me
semble-t-il de faire de la récup
politique mais le sujet la dépendance un
sujet européen l'accroissement de la vie
aujourd'hui fait qu'à plus en plus de
gens qui seront amenés à aller dans ce
type d'établissement alors certes il
faut il faut revoir en france et
ailleurs aussi un les problèmes ils sont
réussis en italie en espagne vous savez
il ya deux pays où le le domaine privé
beaucoup plus important qu'en france
dans les ehpad c'est l'allemagne et la
grande bretagne mais vous avez des pays
comme les nôtres ou pratiquement la
moitié ou un peu plus sans du domaine
public donc il faut revoir ça sent de
fond en comble il faut peut-être mettre
en place un organisme de contrôle
structurelles qui n'existe pas dans
notre pays ça c'est vrai il ya eu un
comité de vigilance qu'elle était mis en
place par xavier bertrand quand il était
mise de la santé mais quelque chose de
structurel qui régulièrement viendrait
contrôler ce qui se passe dans les ehpad
ça c'est une chose mais encore une fois
stéphanie en faire un débat politique
entre les méchants capitalistes et les
gentils du public si c'était aussi
simple et si la maltraitance était que
d'un côté ça serait aussi enfin jacques
myard il n'empêche problèmes structurels
qui revient quand même souvent sur le
tapis l'impuissance des gouvernements on
va voir justement eric revel nous en
parler un de ses investissements la
carte des investissements des ehpad en
europe la france effectivement mais
pourtant l'un des premiers un pays
européens à investir mais par exemple
dans le capital du groupe orpea le plus
gros actionnaire un fonds de pension
canadien on y trouve également
d'ailleurs le groupe peugeot 1 pas
vraiment de rapport entre ces
investisseurs et les établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
indépendantes
quand jean castex nous parle de
davantage de contrôles notamment sur les
écrits dit à sion il n'ya pas quand même
un effort à faire à ce niveau là jacques
mis à écouter je vous dire une chose
lorsque l'établissement
ouvre pour accueillir des personnes
âgées il y a bien sûr tout un dossier à
remplir et il y à des contrôles il faut
que ça réponde à des normes notamment en
matière de sécurité en matière
d'encadrement
c'est ce qui se passe pour vous cacher
dans ma ville où j'ai pratiquement 5 e
et pad certains médicalisé d'autres non
ce qui est certain c'est que ce qui peut
faire c'est revenir régulièrement voir
et contrôler parce qu' il peut y avoir
des dérives dont j'ai entendu sur un
certain nombre de radios que c'était
bien sûr un système qui faisait du fric
et donc il faut éviter que le fric
prédomine et supplante l'humanisme donc
de ce côté là c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure il ne faut pas se laisser
je dirais subjugué par une autorisation
pour toujours il faut y revenir il faut
vérifier et je suis certain que c'est
possible ce que l'on peut reprocher à ce
témoignage que nous avons attendu c'est
qu'on ne bâtit pas je dirais une
sanction une démonstration que tout
espoir eux parce que il y a pu ce qu'a
rapporté par la maille est il faut se
garder pas kaka enfin voyons ça fait
quand même longtemps qu'on en parle il
ya eu ce livre écrit effectivement c'est
pas qu'un témoignage qu'on isole son
autre chaîne alors là il faut pas de
mauvaise foi tout de même aux non désolé
de vous dire on se calme c'est il peut y
avoir un 10 témoignage
regardez ce que cela ait ramené au
nombre de personnes qui sont dans les
ehpad qu'ils soient publics ou qu'ils
soient privés donc deux ans il faut se
calmer on est en train de monter en
épingle une réalité qu'il faut corriger
mais il ne faut pas je dirais
amalgamer l'ensemble du système c'est
indigne et donc vous savez je vous dire
lorsque j'ai fermé la fameuse maison qui
était absolument
inadmissible c'était effectivement une
boîte privée mais il n'en demeure pas
moins que guy compris dans le public
vous pouvez avoir des mouvements c'est
une question de formation du personnel
c'est une question où il faut être
vigilant et je me félicite que le
gouvernement veut mettre en place une
structure qui va être je dirais
continuelle mais il faut se garder mon
jacques maire en tout cas a réagi à
chaud évidemment sur une actualité eric
revel justement en termes de dépendance
comprenons scier le mot c'était aussi
une des promesses de campagne en ce
n'était pas le seul d'ailleurs le avant
lui d'autres mais enfin promesse de
campagne d'emmanuel macro quel est le
bilan
le bilan il est pas bon le bilan il est
pas bon puisque le président la
république effectivement en 2017 avait
promis une grande loi sur la dépendance
il en a reparlé en 2020 mais la remise
dans sa poche cette loi au prétexte que
il y avait des choses plus urgentes à
traiter bon la crise sanitaire la
réforme des retraites ce qu'on peut
remarquer c'est que la crise sanitaire
est toujours là qu'à réforme des
retraites n'a pas été fait mais que
surtout cette grande loi sur la
dépendance qu'avait promise aux 6,1 un
autre dans un autre temps nicolas
sarkozy est toujours dans les cartons
juste un mot quand même sur
l'actionnariat stéphanie si vous
permettez vous citiez tout à l'heure les
actionnaires qu'orpea qui sont des fonds
de pension donc on se dit fonds de
pension c'est évidemment une recherche
du profit maximum mais si vous prenez un
autre très grand groupe d'ehpad comme le
groupe korian je regardais ses
actionnaires c'est le crédit agricole ou
malakoff humanis ce sont des boîtes
françaises qui voilà qui accompagne ce
sont des banques et des assurances mais
je veux dire ce sont des français qui
accompagnent le développement et les
investissements du groupe korian france
donc ce qui est un peu gênant dans tout
ça et je rejoins le point de chaque
milliard ce qui est un peu gênant c'est
que évidemment ça nous touche
directement parce qu'encore une fois il
n'y aurait qu'un seul cas comme celui ci
il serait extrêmement choquant parce que
ça pourrait nous toucher directement
notre mère notre grand mère où notre
temps tu sais il n'y a pas le sujet mais
ce qui est un peu choquant c'est que
j'ai l'impression que là on est en train
de battre tous dans le même sac il ya
sept cent trente mille personnes âgées
qui vivent dans ces milieux là il ya des
abus il ya des maltraitances de toutes
sortes c'est indéniable mais voyez on
est en train de jeter aux orties ce
secteur alors que finalement qu'est-ce
qu'on a d'autres comme choix avec
l'allongement de la durée de vie le ce
le soin à domicile certes mais le soin à
domicile s'est pas non plus extensible
il faut du personnel il faut aussi des
contrôles qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres
possibilités pour essayer d'emmener le
plus loin possible nos chers aînés à ce
genre d'établissement
donc ils font les contrôler mais on va
pas inventer louche du jour au lendemain
et cette espèce de bric à brac dans
lequel on est rentré avec ce bruit
médiatique autour d'un livre les
fossoyeurs on ne prend pas le citer
c'est un c'est un point important mais
comme toujours gardons nous de tous les
amalgames parce que ça mais nous pierre
si merci messieurs on est on est présent
à 21h30 merci à tous les deux en tout
cas d'avoir participé à ce décryptage et
c'est la fin de cette émission rendez
vous dès demain 20h pour un nouveau
numéro excellente fin de soirée à tous
ouverts et france
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans la
grande interview notre invité
aujourd'hui mathieu langlois bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste réanimateur ancien médecin
chef du raid hauteur de médecins du raid
aux éditions albin michel bienvenu sur
ce plateau et merci à d'être parmi nous
mercier ou alors mathieu avant de
revenir sur votre parcours au sein du
raid et sur ce que vous avez vécu vous
avez grandi en région parisienne vous
avez fait des études de médecine et il
me semble qu'à vos 25 ans vous êtes de
garde et vous vivez en événement un peu
particulier
alors c'est là je veux que j'étais en
train de réfléchir chacun voilà donc en
fait la gt gt encore l'étudiant enfin
j'étais jeune
j'étais externe encore donc jeune
étudiant en médecine et je quittais la
montagne pour venir prendre une garde au
samu de 92
et je crois une demi-heure après avoir
récupéré même pas mon mot bip j'ai été
avec un médecin et un ambulancier on
était sur les attentats
au rer b à saint michel est-ce que cet
événement vous avez vécu à confirmer
quelque part votre vocation
il fait partie évidemment des événements
importants qui m'ont ont rassuré on va
dire dans le sens où je
j'avais confiance en moi par rapport à
mon à ce que je devais faire dans des
situations particulièrement difficiles
après j'étais jeune donc
j'avais là aussi la naïveté de la de la
jeunesse
j'étais j'ai heureusement progressé et
est confronté à beaucoup de situations
difficiles qui m'ont permis ensuite
d'avoir une vraie expérience vous
rentrez au raid en 2007 comment est-ce
que cela s'est fait alors en fait j'ai
été recruté par un ami via le sport
qui connaissait mon parcours ni médicale
mais nos relations étaient plus amicale
et sportive et donc c'est lui qui m'a
proposé de rejoindre